Let's see what's going on with people in the
audience.
We're going to go to the phones at (617) 830-4750.
Let's start with our color from the four for
three area code caller from four four, three.
Oh, who's this?
Where are you calling from?
Hey, David back.
My name is Eric.
I'm calling from Baltimore, Maryland.
I do it, but
hey Eric.
Good.
How are you?
Oh, I was just calling about the whole Russia
thing.
I think really that it's time for it's time
to let go of this whole rest of the thing
because even the Democrats like the leadership
in the Democrat Party in Congress and Senate
has completely shifted from Russian collusion
to, I'm sorry, a truck's going by from Russian
collusion to, uh, obstruction of justice.
And I really do think it's just time for the
Democrats to just move on and, you know, just
try to try to beat Trump at the ballot box
instead of just trying to get them out of
office.
Well, listen, Eric, I mean I think you're
right that either way, the fastest removal
of Trump is going to happen by voting them
out in November of 2020.
So it sounds like on that part, you and I
both are on the same page.
I think where I would, um, not necessarily
disagree, but maybe try to refocus your thinking
is that on the one hand, people who are running
in 2020, you need to run the best campaigns
possible.
We've all got to get out and vote.
We've got to make sure that there's not this,
uh, lack of enthusiasm.
But by the left that we're seeing in polls,
which might hold down turn out, but the molar
report does says say there were, there is
substantial evidence of obstruction on the
14 different, uh, obstructive acts that Robert
Mueller analyzed.
The three requirements to meet the legal definition
of obstruction were met in eight of those
14.
So I think it would be wrong to say because
it's faster to beat Trump in November of 2020.
We should ignore the obstruction part.
I think our current elected officials should
deal with the obstruction part and meanwhile
we've got to make sure to go out and vote
in November of 2020.
Okay,
well, well, I, I mean I, I kind of see what
you're saying there, but um, it's just the
whole rest of the whole western narrative.
I mean even you yourself, you've been pushing
the whole k with Donald Trump received help
from the Russians here and this and that.
But there was no Russian collusion mean.
I know we still got to wait
for, you know, Muller to testify.
We don't, it's not going to shed light.
Let's listen, Eric.
I mean, when you, when you, I don't know why
you're pulling me into it.
I've said from, you know, find a clip 13 months
ago where I said, if you're waiting for the
reports to say, Trump personally colluded
with Putin, you're waiting for something that's
never going to happen.
That doesn't change the fact that the Trump
tower meeting happened.
Papadopoulos you know, all of that stuff took
place.
What was, what was misguided if anyone was
doing it, was imagining that the results of
the molar report would be Trump personally
colluded with Putin.
Anyone who was waiting for that certainly
was waiting for something that made no sense.
But again, that to me doesn't change if molar
says in the report there substantial evidence
of obstruction unless you believe molar is
lying, that's a very serious thing.
Well, well, no, you brought up the Trump tower
meeting.
If you even NBC News, uh, admitted that you
can look this up, a Google ad or whatever
you do the, I can't remember the lady's name,
the Russian lawyer lady who met, she met with
Glenn Simpson using gps before and after the
Don Jr Trump tower meeting.
Okay.
That, that, that's well known documented news.
So it was, it seemed like more of like a setup.
And then you brought in,
wait, hold on Eric.
And what knows, what was the center who was
setting who up to do what?
They sent the Russian lawyer into Trump tower.
Okay.
We have information on Hillary Clinton or
whatever
they being a big thing.
Glenn Simpson is the founder of using GPS,
which was hired by Perkins Cooling, which
is a Democrat Party Law.
Okay.
So, so when you seeing what you're asserting
is that offering dirt on Hillary to the Trump
campaign was a setup by Democrats to see if
they could dance
DNC.
This is, this is well known, documented news.
Okay.
All right, Eric.
Well, listen, you're, you're going into an
area that, um, is, is a little bit disconnected
from reality.
So I'm going to let you go, but I appreciate
your help and, and uh, in, in sorting this
out.
Um, but, uh, you know, I think we can walk
and chew gum at the same time the obstruction
needs to be dealt with and we got to win in
November of 2020.